hi everyone it's jerry let's have a look
at a game between bobby fischer on the
white end and jovan zafrebski
this was played at the 1967 skopje
tournament
about four years ago i covered a game
from this very event
i titled the video
bobby fischer wins with the fischer
sozen attack in 17 moves
that was fisher's fourth round game
played on august 10th against peter
delhi
fast forward 13 rounds and 20 days
and we arrive here
fisher against international master
jovan sofrevsky
so fischer is using this same weapon
a weapon he helped to develop
the fischer-sozen attack
to score another win at this same
tournament
let's see how he did it
opening wise
we have an open sicilian
another thing we might say is this
variation
uh this fischer-sozen attack helped
propel fischer to victory in the event
it was a close finish
fischer ended up with 13 and a half
points and
his next nearest competitor was at 13.
okay
the key move bishop to c4 key move in
this variation stare at the weakest
square in black's camp f7
so e6
paves the way for king side deployment
and remains strong
on the light squares tries to tame
that bishop on c4
it's much better posted on b3
less accessible to pawn advances
and there's even that little center fork
trick that can surface a capture on e4
followed up with
a double attack on c4 and e4
white side steps all of that
bishop e7 bishop e3
a key difference
in the two games i've drawn your
attention to so far his game against
peter delhi and this one here
is
the location of white's king
in this game fisher opts for queenside
castles
not king side
okay
king side for black in this game
and queen e2 not just to any square
we're not just
rolling the dice flipping a coin d2 or
e2 we're keeping a watchful eye over g4
so that our bishop is a little happier
stable
all right queen a5 queenside castles
captures on e4
and bishop to d7 it's the only square
for that guy
c6 looks like a good post and black is
also
maybe
helping to support this b5 advance
and
maybe in just a little bit black's ready
to question the stability of the knight
on c3
all right
white with king to b3 is
completing we can say queen side castles
king is almost always going to want to
be a little bit closer hugging that a2
pawn
getting off of
the half open c file as well
all right
from here rook a to d8
and queen to e3 so this is my first of
three pop quizzes in this game
what's my question here what is queen to
e3
doing
feel free to pause the video
okay
i'll just point out what
uh i initially saw queen to e3 queen to
e3 doing
it's forming a battery it's threatening
to know win the a7 pawn
that was really the only
thought i had
when i saw queen to e3
um
i believe fisher already has
this eventual trick this eventual
plan up his sleeve when he's playing
queen to e3
and it was only after i played through
some moves that i realized oh
yeah there's a second idea behind queen
to e3
we'll see what that is soon enough
first how does black address this
threat on a7
black plays b6
seems uh
seems good enough
you'll notice a6 isn't really helping
you're you're in that kind of pickle you
get forked
the computer points out you know what
who cares about a7 play b5 don't be too
concerned about losing a pawn
we are castled on opposite wings after
all and
we should be giving more value to these
open lines
all right
well b5 was not played
b6 it is in the game and now we have
move 14
bishop takes knight
and
best is for black to
keep the structure as is
in recapture with the bishop
um
why didn't black play that well
be dropping this pawn
in the end the computer says that
there's some compensation that black has
it's not quite a full
pawn advantage that white enjoys here
black after all has the bishop pair the
extra pawn white has is on the king side
not so easy to really get that guy
rolling in this environment
okay
some compensation but you know for a
human can totally understand why you
would want to say all right you know
what i'll compromise my king side a
little bit but i'm not giving up my d6
point
okay
well pop quiz number two coming up white
to move what would you play or what is
your plan here
as white
feel free to pause the video
okay
the star move of this game
the one that certainly grabbed my
attention
is knight to d5
that
that's a move that sparkles
um
let me uh those of you who
um
didn't come up with
that move let me
let me provide some tips for you
to
maybe
make it so that you have a better chance
of
finding those type of moves maybe
after what i share
you know you'll have a
it becomes a little more likely that
that might cross your mind
so here it goes for one
intersection squares
the biggest intersection square in the
position is d5 for white at least
maybe just in the whole position
altogether
look at all the different pieces that
converge there
very often
piece jumps to those points surface
that's one thing to focus on
and another
is
uh
the black pawn structure it has been
compromised
and currently
we can identify one of the black pawns
as
a
most important black pawn
the most important black pawn in this
position the one that's worth the most
is this guy here on e6 why do i think
this it's because without that pawn
the structure is
a complete wreck
without the pawn on e6
d6 f6
f7 would all be what
isolated
and
the d5 square would as a result
be a big hole that
multiple white pieces can make use of
what am i really getting at in drawing
your attention to this e6 pawn
it's to maybe view that pawn as being
worth much more
than just a point if you were to see
that e6 pawn as worth two
maybe two and a half points
maybe you think a little bit more about
diving a knight into this square
is it really you giving up
three points and only getting a point in
return
maybe not
okay
what is black's reply here
in the game we have
rook to e8
doesn't bite on d5 and this game ends up
finishing
a bit more
decisively but in a much more calm
looking environment where white is
simply up a couple
pawns
the real question here is what happens
if the knight is captured so let's have
a look
what's the
follow-up after pawn captures knight
the idea here fischer had in mind is to
take with the rook
gaining a valuable tempo against the
queen
so that white can next
form a battery
to have
some kind of queen rook battery on the
h-file
and
mate the black king
and what would black have in reply to
this
if queen to b4 the queen's actually
toast after a3 or even c3
so
she'd have to let's say go to a6
pop quiz number three
final one of this video
there's only one winning continuation
here for white
what is it what's the
next move that white must play in order
to win
feel free to pause the video
okay
the only
winning continuation
is
rook to h5
i'm drawing attention to this because
move order is extremely important in
this position
you may think that you can play queen h6
first and then rook to h5 and
we're getting at h7 that's not the case
it's important to start with rook h5
first
what's the issue if you play queen h6
first
well there's a couple different moves
black can play here i'll just highlight
one
uh well there's queen e2 and bishop to
c6 i'll just make the bishop c6 move
i'll show this variation
bishop c6 can follow
hitting the rook
and keeps a watchful eye on the e4 pawn
so
that means after rook h5 the bishop
would be there
just in the nick of time
to save the black king
defend
the king's side defend h7
so by starting with whoops
by first starting with
rook to h5
if bishop c6 here we can simply address
the thread on e4
with f3
and next up
sweep into h6
and there's not going to be a good
solution to the mate on h7
not even sure what move to put on here
for black as a try rook here isn't
really doing anything
queen here
check checkmate nearby
no good solution to that
so
um
oh one final note
another helpful tip here i think at
least is
you know
if you're not able to calculate if
it can be quite easy to miss out on this
move bishop to c6
something that i like to do in my own
games
uh
i like to you know if we're looking at
two different moves we want to stack the
rooks the major pieces on the h file
which move
which piece right these two want to
eventually be on the h file which of the
two is least flexible
which one has fewer options
the rook
the rook only has that h5 square
the queen on the other hand
yes she has h6 but maybe in some
variations she may want to pivot on g3
with the check
so
i like to sometimes follow this
move the piece with the fewest options
first
and in this case it's the rook
maybe that would be helpful for many of
you
anyhow
how did the game ultimately finish
we had rook to e8
white simply took the bishop on
e7
took on d6 completely falling apart
queen d4 hitting the bishop
and the pawn on f6
white one now a second pawn that is move
19 this one's over
black resigns
it's nothing to play for here you're
down two pawns your queen is on f6 you
can't get rid of it
perfectly healthy structure
for white
you name it everything is tipping in
white's favor
so
yeah a really nice game uh knight to d5
is definitely one of those moves
that sparkles and yeah
hopefully you were able to take a thing
or two away
from this brief game
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback in the comments section below
and
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you